la séance est ouverte le compterendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserve
d'usage notre ordre du jour appelle les
explications de vote et le vote à la
tribune du projet de loi de finances
pour
2024 je donne immédiatement la parole
pour le groupe les républicains à Madame
Christine Lavarde elle a 7
minutes avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
1363 amendements à l'automne 2017 mon
premier PLF
3756 amendements cette année 7 ans plus
tard plus 175 % l'inflation
parlementaire dépasse très largement
l'inflation monétaire il est grand temps
que notre autorité de régulation mette
fin à cette politique expansionniste
nous n'avons malheureusement plus de
marge de manœuvre 7 jours et 6 nuits
consécutives pour la première partie 8
jours et presque autant de nuits de
longues nuits pour la seconde partie les
organismes ont été mis à Rud épreuve
notre rapporteur général plusieurs
administrateurs de la commission des
finances certes il existe quelques
pauses pour les sénateur même si
monsieur le Président la pause est
parfois courte entre la fin de la séance
de nuit et la séance de commission des
financeces qui suit le même jour la même
matinée pas de pause pour les agents de
la commission des finances pas de pause
pour les agents de la direction de la
séance je pense que nous pouvons tous
les remercier chaleureusement et
[Applaudissements]
et une fois n'est pas coutume monsieur
le ministre je souhaite aussi remercier
les ministres qui globalement ont joué
le jeu du débat pour exemple pas moins
de quatre ministres ont siégé pendant la
discussion de la mission écologie je
tiens monsieur le ministre à vous
remercier vous vous avez fait
l'intégralité de ce projet de loi de
finances vous êtes resté avec nous 6
jours et 7ette
nuit c'était c'est la première fois
depuis 7 ans que j'observe un ministre
qui réussit cette épreuve et c'était
votre premier
PLF merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre pour votre écoute merci pour vos
réponses mais aussi pour vos non
réponses et je ne voudrais pas vous
redire que les 35000 communes de France
aimerait connaître le calendrier
budgétaire qui s'imposera à elle au 1er
janvier alors à la suite du cardinal de
Richelieu qui nous surveille tous dans
le salon des messagers la politique
n'est pas l'art du possible c'est de
rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire et
ce qui est nécessaire c'est réduire
rapidement notre déficit le deuxième le
plus élevé de la zone euro c'est
commencer à rembourser notre dette dont
la charge d'intérêt explose et
l'achoppement des discussions du conseil
écopine sur la révision du pacte de
stabilité le weekend dernier tout
particulièrement sur les modalités du
bras correctif à savoir les efforts qui
seront demandés aux États-membres en
procédure de déficit excessif montrre
combien la position de la France est
fragilisée sur la scène européenne du
seul fait de ces mauvais résultats
économiques la majorité sénatoriale a
fait de la politique dans le bon sens du
terme nous avons été capable de proposer
des choix responsables des choix à
l'europrès
par exemple nous vous avons proposé et
voté de limiter le soutien aux apprentis
les plus diplômés nous avons recentré
les dispositifs de soutien face à la
hausse des prix de l'électricité sur les
plus modestes et oui monsieur le
ministre dans notre esprit il s'agit
bien d'un accompagnement vers la fin de
la politique du chèque cependant je vous
le dis il faudra penser à une réforme
car une partie de la population ne
pourra pas payer de manière durable de
l'électricité à plus de 220 € par mgawh
nous avons refusé la création d'un
paradis fiscal pour la FIFA nous avons
transformé une nouvelle fois l'impôt sur
la fortune immobilière en impôt sur la
fortune improductive ainsi ce sont plus
de 7 milliards d'euros d'économie qui
ont été voté et ce ne sont pas des
économies au détriment du défi de la
transition écologique ou de la
croissence ce sont de vraies économies
pas des économies de papier l'effort de
redressement des finance de l'État est
réelle et non porté exclusivement par la
disparition progressive et inéluctable
des mesures de crise cet effort permet
d'avoir un déficit public inférieur à 3
% dès 2025 monsieur le ministre notre
trajectoire de loi de programmation des
finances publiques est
réaliste lors de la discussion générale
en seconde lecture du projet de loi de
finance d'ailleurs vous nous aviez dit
nous faisons le pari de la confiance
avec les collectivités territoriales
nous travaillons à une nouvelle méthode
avec les les élus cette méthode quelle
est-elle c'est la non application du
principe de qui décide paye dans deux
articles de ce projet de loi vous avez
imposé aux collectivités des
exonérations non composées de taxes sur
le foncier bâti j'ai bien compris
monsieur le ministre que vous
personnellement ne partagiez pas cette
philosophie vous avez introduit une
réforme des budgets verts pour quasiment
toutes les communes dès 2024 alors que
jusqu'à présent ce sont uniquement les
grandes collectivités qui l'ont
expérimenté nous sommes bien bien
évidemment pour l'objectif qui est
poursuivi nous remettons uniquement en
cause la méthode le Sénat a voté des
dispositions vous permettant de mettre
en œuvre ce Paris de la confiance ce
Paris de la réussite de l'action
décentralisée quelques exemples le fond
climat territorial l'affectation d'une
fraction du produit des quôas carbon aux
autorités organisatrices de la mobilité
le maintien du BTZ dans le UF sur
l'ensemble du territoire une meilleure
définition des FRR à alors avant de
voter en faveur de ce projet de loi de
finance le groupe les républicains a
bien quelques regrets notamment exprimé
lors de les explication de vote de la
première partie le rejet de la hausse du
plafond du cootient familial alors que
la baisse de la natalité est un défi
aussi important que le défi de la dette
d'ailleurs ces deux défis sont liés la
hausse de la fiscalité taxation des haut
revenus des rachats d'actions imposition
sur les revenus de l'assurance vie et de
l'épargne logement mais Monsieur le
Ministre dès après raison travaillons au
projet de loi de finance pour 2025 cela
évitera les trop nombreux articles
additionnels de la navette cela évitera
des discussions en séance pour cause
d'impréparation ou de défaut
d'information voici quelques sujets la
taxe de séjour la fiscalité de la
location de des courtes durées la les
ressources des chambres consulaires la
réforme du régime d'indemnisation des
catastrophes naturelles la réforme de la
fiscalité de l'eau la condition du
succès et le partage de l'information
quand aurons-nous connaissance des
fiches d'évaluation des dépenses
fiscales arrivées à échéance monsieur le
ministre vous trouverez encore face à
vous l'année prochaine une opposition
attentive mais constructive sur les bans
du groupe les républicains pour rendre
possible ce qui est nécessaire pour une
France tournée vers
l'avenir merci ma cher
collègue pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figur sur la liste
d'cun groupe je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur Stéphane RER il a 3
minutes et bien c'est bienable à vous
monsieur président monieur
bonjour monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
dernier budget de l'État en excédent a
été voté fin
1973 c'était il y a 50 ans sous Georg
Pompidou après les 30 glorieuses nous
bouclons les 50 piteuses avec encore un
déficit de 44 milliards d'euros pour
l'année à venir François Fillon alors
Premier ministre avoué en 2011 qu'il
était à la tête d'un État en faillite il
y avait alors 1500 milliards de dettes
que devrions-nous dire de notre
situation actuelle alors que la dette a
plus que doublé pour atteindre les 3000
milliards la seule charge de cette dette
explose à 52 milliards d'euros l'an
prochain le risque de de devenir le
premier poste budgétaire devant
l'éducation nationale notre endettement
passe à près de 110 % du PIB en 2024 là
où il était de 98 % en 2017 depuis 1973
à défaut de poches de pétrole en France
les gouvernements successifs ont décidé
de faire les poches des Français et le
forage fonctionne à plein régime
aujourd'hui les prélèvements
obligatoires en France représentent 48 %
du PIB sur 100 € de production de
richesse 48 € vont à la sphère publique
c'est 6,3 points de plus que le taux
moyen des autres pays européens au vu de
ce record vos marges de manœuvre sont
nuls vous ne parviendrez pas à
désendetter le pays lutter contre
l'inflation et investir pour l'avenir
sans remettre en question le système
économique actuel de socialisme
tentaculaire à l'intérieur du pays et de
libéralisme sans entrave à l'extérieur
pour retrouver de la croissance il faut
moins d'impôts et de normes pour
développer nos industries réduites de
moitié depuis les années 70 et moins
d'accords de libre échangee monsieur
entre l'Union européenne et le Mercosur
en cours de négociation ou entre l'Union
européenne et la Nouvelle-Zélande qui
soumett à concurrence déloyales nos
paysans aujourd'hui les impôts de
production s'élèvent à plus de 100
milliards d'euros quatre fois plus que
l'Allemagne pour répondre à cela votre
gouvernement qui survit grâce à sa
perfusion permanente de 493 a déigné
supprimer la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises et pour cause
cette baisse d'impôt ne viendra pas
grèver son train de vie mais le budget
des collectivités
territoriale déjà exangue c'est tout
bonnement irresponsable il n'y a plus
d'État stratège plus d'investissement
stratégique malgré un Haut Commissariat
au Plan pas de
réindust réindustrialisation viable pas
de pas de plan d'infrastructure l'État
doit se se réformer pour parvenir un
libéralisme national libéré à
l'intérieur et protégé à l'extérieur
Emmanuel Macron avait promis 60
milliards d'économies par an en 2017 il
a aggravé la dette de 700 milliards
Édouard Philippe a parlé d'addiction
française à la dépense publique et nous
avons eu le quoi qu'il en coûte
macronien pour infin le ministre de
l'Économie finisse par planter le
dernier clou dans le cercueil du mythe
du Mozart de la finance en avouant que
nous sommes finalement à l'euro prê en
tant que sénateur dont la fonction est
celle de contrôler ce que vous faites de
l'argent du contribuable je m'opposerai
bien évidemment à ce projet de lo de
finan merci monsieur le Président la
parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et
territoire monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers
collègues ce dimanche ravier miley est
officiellement devenu le nouveau
président de la République argentine
c'est la première fois qu'un candidat
autoproclamé libertarien arrive aux plus
hautes
responsabilités le populisme et le
dégagisme ont trouvé un nouveau
carburant la réduction radicale des
dépenses
publiques une image a marqué la campagne
de My on le voit rugir comme un fou en
brandissant une tronçonneuse le nouveau
président promet de juguler l'inflation
en tronçonnant la dépense publique le
message est on peu plus clair ça va
saigner dans la première interview qu'il
a donné après son élection milay a
déclaré je cite l'équilibre budgétaire
est non négociable c'est zéro déficit et
si un ministre présente un budget en
déficit je le vire fin de
citation je veux rassurer tous mes
collègues qui redoutent sans cesse
l'international de l'ultralibéralisme
la France en est encore loin il faudrait
d'abord qu'elle se réconcilie avec le
libéralisme le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 n'a rien d'un budget à la
tronçonneuse c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est un budget pragmatique qui
nous ramène lentement mais sûrement dans
les clous de nos engagements européen
les dépenses ont augmenté la dette aussi
mais le déficit est contenu ça de 4,5 %
et l'inflation limitée à
2,6 on est loin de l'austérité qui
s'annonce sous les cieux
argentins le texte du Gouvernement place
la France sur une trajectoire
raisonnable elle nous laisse encore
espérer un retour à la normale sans
ajustement
brutal la commission des finances a
proposé d'accélérer un peu le rythme
monsieur le ministre si vous choisissiez
de suivre le train sénateur
vous arriveriez un peu plus vite à votre
objectif de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques nous avons fait de nombreuses
propositions pour limiter la hausse des
dépenses c'est le cas sur la mission
travail et emploi dont j'ai l'honneur de
rapporter les crédits avec ma collègue
gisline
sen le recentrage de l'apprentissage sur
les artisans et les PME permettrait de
réaliser 725 millions d'euros d'économie
par an ça mérite que l'on s'y intéresse
je m'y attarde d'ailleurs un instant car
il me semble ce point important vous
savez monsieur le ministre l'attachement
qui est le nôtre chez les indépendants à
l'apprentissage depuis 2017 à titre
personnel je l'ai toujours salué et
défendu au nom de la commission des
finances du Sénat et je veux être très
clair l'essort de l'apprentissage est
une victoire économique et culturelle
décisive pour la
France cependant on ne peut pas vouloir
rompre avec le quoi qu'il en coûte sans
optimiser l'utilisation des donniers
publics en l'occurrence l'essentiel
c'est de soutenir les artisans et les
PME qui recrutent qui forment des
apprentis plutôt que de risquer
d'entretenir une obè pour les grands
groupes je ne sais pas si vous
retiendrez cette mesure j'espère en tout
cas qu'elle contribuera à renforcer et à
péreniser l'apprentissage qui est une
chance pour tous nos jeunes et j'espère
que cette mesure ouvrira l'opportunité
d'une concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux j'en profite pour saluer le
rapporteur général qui a proposé
plusieurs pistes pour réduire nos
dépenses publiques notre groupe soutient
cette démarche cela vaut notamment pour
la maîtrise de la masse salariale de
l'État à l'initiative de la Commission
des finances le Sénat propose
d'économiser 150 millions d'euros en
réduisant les effectifs des opérateurs
de l'État charge au gouvernement
désormais d'identifier les opérateurs
qui pourront faire mieux avec moi il est
nécessaire de réaliser ces économies
même si aucune économie n'est jamais
populaire c'est le prix à payer pour
continuer à investir dans les missions
régaliennes de l'État je le disais au
tout début de l'examen du budget notre
groupe soutient le renforcement de
l'État dans ses missions
régaliennes je me réjouis à cet égard de
la hausse significative des budgets de
la défense des forces de l'ordre et de
la justice si nous voulons rétablir
l'autorité de l'État il faut nous en
donner les moyens mes chers collègues
alors que les menaces se multi à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur de nos
frontières ce réarmement matériel est
indispensable indispensable car
préalable au réarmement moral dont no
dont nos démocraties fatiguées ont tant
besoin réaliser des économies là où
c'est possible pour investir là où c'est
indispensable tel est mes chers
collègues la ligne que notre groupe a
tenté de suivre tout au long de ce
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 c'est
pourquoi dans un esprit de
responsabilité nous avons voté la
majorité des économies proposées par la
Commission
pourtant toutes les économies ne sont
pas bonnes à prendre le rejet plusieurs
missions importantes au premier rang
desqueles les missions immigration et
cohésion des territoires emputent le
budget de l'État de manière
artificiel je regrette que la majorité
sénatoriale n'it pas fait des
propositions pour adapter pour adopter
tous les
crédits sur ces crédits ne pas adopter
certaines missions c'est ne pas assumer
certains
parce qu'il manque de crédit je crains
que le budget ne manque finalement de
crédibilité cela fait penser à une autre
image qui a marqué la campagne du
nouveau président argentin on le voit
passer devant un tableau où sont àter
les différents ministères de son pays un
à un il il arrache les postites en
criant
dehors c'est ainsi que les populistes
s'attaquent à réduire la dette publique
mes chers collègues je pense qu'il
existe un chemin plus raisonnable pour
rétablir nos comptes le groupe Les
Indépendants salue les économies
présentées dans ce budget mais regrette
le rejet de certains crédits c'est
pourquoi dans sa majorité il
s'abstiendra sur ce texte et puisqu'il
me reste une trentaine de secondes j'en
profite moi aussi pour saluer le
président de la commission des finances
pour la tenue de nos débats malgré près
de 4000 amendements cette année et je
salue également la présence l'assiduité
du ministre et son écoute qui a été
remarqué je le crois MERCI BEAUCOUP
merci la paroleur général jeavais déjà
faitér évidemment le rapporteur général
aussi mais je l'avais déjà
dit la parole est à notre collègue
Michel canevette pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues le
groupe de l'Union centriste est
particulièrement préoccupé par l'état
des finances publiques il y a 10 ans si
l'on rapporte la dette au PIB il y avait
SEP pays de la zone euro derrière nous
aujourd'hui il y a l'Italie et la Grèce
derrière nous alors Vincent deaet a
souvent eu l'occasion ici de solliciter
la règle d'or je pense que c'est
quelques chose à quoi il faudra que l'on
puisse réfléchir et mettre en œuvre si
l'on veut que l'on reste que l'on
restaure la capacité d'action de notre
pays alors le groupe de l'Union
centriste dans ce débat a visé deux
objectifs d'une part améliorer les
recettes pour améliorer la situation
financière de l'État et d'autre part
maîtriser les dépenses je reviendrai
tout à l'heure sur l'amélioration des
recettes mais il importe peut-être de
voir la maîtrise des dépenses on arrive
pour ce qui concerne les propositions
centriste environ à 2 milliards 2
milliards C d'amélioration des recettes
de l'État et euh grosso modo nous avons
soutenu l'amélioration des dépenses la
maîtrise des dépenses à hauteur de 7
milliards d'euros c'estdire l'effort qui
a été fait et donc les collègues
centristes notamment ont été très
offensifs sur les questions d'habitat
Lana tuanie par exemple a évoqué les
questions d'habitat en outreem giselin
Combier a rappelé qu'il y avait un
besoin de 5 millions de logements dans
les 10 ans qui viennent et
qu'aujourd'hui la situation c'est 28 %
de permis de construire en moins 40 % de
crédit en moins 38 % des transactions en
moins Denis SAÉ a évoqué la nécessité de
la concrétisation de la rénovation
énergétique Jean ingrè c'est quant à
lui porté sur la nécessité les besoins
pour le logement des des étudiants et
puis Françoise Gatel a bien entendu
évoqué aussi les besoins des
collectivités territoriales en matière
de financement pour la rénovation de
l'ensemble du bâti tandis que
Jean-François langau a sollicité une
meilleure programmation pluriannuelle
sur différents éléments comme la
biodiversité comme sur les relations
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales et puis bien entendu sur
la transition énergétique également en
matière d'enseignement Anne Sophie
romagie a évoqué la réussite de
l'apprentissage mais elle a rappelé les
difficultés financière de France
compéten Annique billon elle a hélas
évoqué les les résultats
particulièrement décevants au regard des
classements internationaux tout ceci à
remettre dans un contexte où je vous
rappelle les résultats au bac dans notre
pays sont de 90,7 % c'estd l'écart entre
les résultats en France et notre
comparaison internationale en matière de
d'économie je rappelle qu'il y a dans
l'action de l'État monsieur le ministre
plus de 400 types d'aide il va être
temps de ration analiser les choses si
l'on veut vraiment être beaucoup plus
efficace parce que beaucoup ont le
sentiment que les ces sont vont toujours
au même et à cet égard Daniel Fargeot a
évoqué la place des des réseaux
consulaires a évoqué aussi en matière
d'agriculture les nécessités du
renouvellement des générations et de
l'amélioration du revenu des des
agriculteurs if blunven a également
évoqué la nécessité d'une évaluation du
soutien à l'investissement productif et
François Vincent capo canadellas a lui
aussi évoquer la nécessité de
l'évaluation des actions du plan de
relance
concernant la réforme de France travail
que Brigitte Deva a évoqué elle a évoqué
notamment l'impact sur l'emploi qui
qu'il faudra évaluer dans le domaine
social notre collègue Nadia sologou a
fait montre d'une ambition de la
prévention en matière de santé c'est
nécessaire et accessoirement sur les
anciens combattants et la mémoire elle a
souhaité que l'appellation évolue vers
le monond de combattant et Joseline
guidez a rappelé les besoins en matière
d'aide alimentaire ils sont
particulièrement dissipés monsieur le
Président en terme d'administration
Jean-Michel Arnaud a évoqué les
difficultés à obtenir des titres
sécurisés je pense au titre de séjour je
pense aussi au titre d'identité et puis
bien entendu aux questions du du permis
de conduire Olivia Richard ses plaintes
quant à elle des délais de traitement de
la justice administrative et Philippe
boncarer a évoqué les résultats
particulièrement décevants en matière de
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
rappelant notamment qu' nous avons
actuellement plus de 180 titres de
séjour différents dans notre pays qu'il
convient donc de rationaliser là aussi
Claude KNE quand à lui a évoqué la
promotion du sport santé Olivier
cholotti les difficultés à recruté dans
le domaine militaire malgré
l'augmentation des crédits Olivier
cadiic et Philippe folot sont apesanti
sur la francophonie effectivement qu'il
convient de promouvoir Catherine Mor
Deli a appelé l'attention sur le
financement d'audiovisuel qui ne peut
continuer par le recours à la FCTVA et
puis Sonia de la provoté a évoqué la
nécessité d'une stratégie en direction
du patrimoine et s'est inquiété du
devenir des écoles supérieures d'art et
puis enfin je tiens à noter deux
avancées notables qui sont celles de
bernardc pour ce qui concerne France
ruralité revitalisation c'est important
et Françoise Gattel pour ce qui
concerne la prise en compte des communes
nouvelles c'est aussi particulièrement
significatif voyez que l'apport des
centristes a été particulièrement
important làdedans
mais il ne l'a pas été que pour les
dépenses il l' été aussi pour les
recettes et là monsieur le ministre il
faut que vraiment vous écoutiez les
propositions des centristes Nathalie
Goulet Nathalie Goulet vous a formulé de
nombreuses proposition pour lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale contre
l'optimisation fiscale il est nécessaire
d'agir plus vigureeusement en la matière
sinon nous irons au devant de la
difficulté Bernard delcro vous a proposé
une contribution exceptionnel sur les
trèshauts revenus et la taxation des
rachats d'action par les grandes
sociétés sonts régulièrement dé voilà
des propositions concrètes syv vermeill
vous a proposé de transformer l'impô sur
la fortune immobilière en impô sur la
fortune improductive voilà des
propositions très concrètes et puis le
groupe vous a également proposé la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
fiscal n'ayons pas peur d'avancer à la
matière car il faut être plus juste plus
égalitaire c'est le sens du vote de du
groupe centriste
la parole est
à notre collègue grégoryi blanc pour le
groupe écologie solidarité et territoire
vous avez la
parolesieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le monde d'après est désormais
sous nos yeux et nos débats n'y ont pas
échappé et ont clairement tourné autour
de trois enjeux tout d'abord nous sommes
entrés dans un nouveau cycle au niveau
monétaire il nous faut à présent
anticiper des chocs d'inflation à
répétition et la moindre étincelle
diplomatique étant susceptible de mettre
le feu aux liquidité massivement injecté
depuis 2008 avec le resserrement
monétaire les politiques budgétaires
sont désormais au centre des politiques
économiques hors de ce point de vue un
déficit de 150 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire la moitié des recettes
nettes de l'État impactent nos marges de
manœuvre au niveau social l'accès au
logement l'habitat et les mixités se
trouvent au cœur des tensions né de
l'accentuation des mobilités
intrafamiliales professionnelles
migratoires et culturelles d'un côté et
des angoisses sociales nées du
terrorisme de la guerre du choc des
pandémies de l'autre au niveau
environnemental enfin la planète a
franchi 6 des neuf limites vitales et
l'effort n'est pas suffisant pour faire
face les accords de Paris fixai la
limite à +
1,5°gr nous allons vers + 3°gr et le
gouvernement nous enjoint à nous
préparer à + 4 degrés il faut donc à la
fois poursuivre un effort intense pour
éviter le réchauffement mais aussi et
surtout nous adapter en urgence 66
milliards d'euros par an d'ici 2040 dit
le rapport Pisani mafous le FMI est sur
les mêmes ordres de grandeur et dans les
faits nous ne sommes même pas à la
moitié face à ces défis que propose le
gouvernement certes d'amorcer un virage
prix avec la planification écologique et
c'est une première mais avec seulement 7
milliards d'euros et encore en recyclant
des crédits on est très loin du compte
au niveau des inégalités sociale et
patrimonial aucune correction au
contraire fondamentalement tout cela se
traduit par une doxa stabilité fiscale
entretenant au passage une confusion
supplémentaire et c'est là le plus grave
entre stabilité du système fiscal et
stabilité du niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires or ni l'un ni l'autre ne
résiste au fait notre système fiscal va
se prendre de
plein
ce n'est pas clair nous avons besoin
d'un état stratège définissant des
orientations et mobilisant les moyens
appropriés un état qui fixe un cap et
définisse un
projet une politique financière ne fait
pas une politique budgétaire encore
moins une politique économique et encore
moins une politique de transition
écologique alors de ce compé de son côté
comment le Sénat lui a traité CE PLF là
aussi pas de modification structurelle
la majorité sénatoriale a fait sienne la
confusion entre stabilité fiscale et
stabilité du niveau des prélèvements
elle a même voté plusieurs amendements
non gagés qui enfonteront du déficit et
de la dette à l'image de la reprise du
dispositif dit baladure sur le logement
faire baisser les impôts pour
quelquesuns par la dette pour tous est à
nos yeux inacceptable alors à ce budget
il y a certes eu des avancées timides
que nous saluons la correction salutaire
des malfaçon fiscale à l'image des
meublés de tourisme ou de la taxation
sur les rachats d'actions ou encore le
renforcement du soutien au collectivité
locale via la DGF les fonds de
péréquation ou encore la création de la
dotation bioclimatique proposition
historique du groupe écologie solidarité
territoire mais sur l'ensemble mes
collègues et moi avons formulé d'autres
propositions face au défi
environnemental nous devons repenser en
profondeur ce que signifie le
consentement à l'impôt c'est une
question démocratique et nous le savons
bien qui est de premier ordre faire
l'autruche ne fera qu'empirer le
problème et de ce point de vue vu la
situation dégradée des finances que
chacunigne ici nous ne partageons pas
l'idée de baisser les impôts de
production il faut les repenser sans
doute mais pas les baisser pour les
baisser de même la fiscalité sur le
patrimoine doit être revisitée parce que
il n'y a pas d'autre voie que de
prélever les richesses qui dorment non
pas de manière confiscatoire mais de
manière équitable et efficace parce que
sans ressources nouvelles on ne passera
pas et l'ISF climatique qui a été ici
refusé en est le symbole vous n'aurez
d'autre choix que d'y venir la dette de
notre point de vue n'est pas un tabou si
et seulement si elle permet d'abord de
financer l'essentiel avant de baisser
les impôts vous vous faites l'inverse et
de notre point de vue c'est un
contresens économique social et
écologique enfin dans cette période de
crise nous avons proposé de mieux
soutenir le logement social modèle qui a
fait ses preuves en
2008 au moment de la crise de la
promotion
immobilière mais aussi pour construire
immédiatement les Français attend un
toit à tarif abordable et qu'on
construise en respectant la planète pour
innover pour aider les élus locaux pour
montrer qu'on peut passer le zan le
meilleur outil c'est le logement social
alors sur tous ces sujets nous avons
proposé des solutions à la fois
pragmatiques et plus ambitieuses elles
ne sont pas retenues nous voterons en
cohérence contre ce projet puisque j'ai
moi aussi 30 secondes comme mon collègue
de ménéloir tout à l'heure je voudrais
enfin saluer le président de la
commission le rapporteur général et
l'ensemble des agents qui ont contribué
à ce cè à ce ce budget et à ces débats
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
2024 va s'ouvrir comme le dirait un
collègue de notre groupe c'est
maintenant que les affaires se corsent
merci de votre attention
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pascal Savoldi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
[Applaudissements]
kanaki la
parole B un petit
allez monsieur le Président j'allais
dire messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues à l'ône d'un scrutin
d'une telle importance pour l'avenir de
notre pays il est indispensable de se
demander dans quel contexte notre vote
intervient-il à contrario de ce
qu'affirment les ministres en 2023
un/art des ménages a connu des fin de
mois à découvert pendant au moins plus
de 3 mois consécutifs près de 4 français
sur 10 sont renoncer à des soins alors
qu'ils en avaient besoin la Banque de
France prévoit un effondrement de
l'investissement des ménages - 5,8 % en
2023 5,9 % en 2024 l'état social
continue donc à se dégrader l'année 2023
était celle d'une vulnérabilité
climatique jamais atteinte et qui touche
plus sévèrement les plus modestes aussi
une seule question mérite d'être posé
est-ce que la vie des gens va aller
mieux avec ce projet de loi de finance
la réponse est pour nous non et ce pour
trois raisons la première c'est la
limite démocratique inhérente à ce
projet d'abord celle d'avoir été pensé
sans la représentation nationale et je
vous cite monsieur le ministre je vous
cite j'assume qu'on ait besoin du 493
sur le budget c'était le 9 octobre soit
8 jours avant l'ouverture du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est celle
d'avoir ignoré des alertes citoyennes
les syndicalistes des maires des grandes
associations de solidarité bien sûr
chers collègues nous avons eu au Sénat
un débat financier mais il a été en
partie biaisé par des combinaison
politique électorale et quelques
prétentions individuelles du au
quinquena et à des législatives
dépendant de l'élection présidentielle
ce sont tous ces éléments qui ont amené
notre groupe à proposer une motion de
rejet préalable celle-ci ayant été
rejetée nous avons proposé l'élaboration
d'un contrebudget d'initiative citoy yen
constitué de plus de 150 propositions de
recette mais aussi de relance de
l'économie des services publics et du
pouvoir d'achat quelquesunes ont été
adoptées notamment pour renforcer la
taxation des rachats d'action sur les
logements vacants pour supprimer les
cadeaux fiscaux fédération sportive
internationale et quelques gestes sur la
faute friscale et nous nous félicitons
de ce travail mais dans l'ensemble nos
proposition celles des autres
composantes de l'opposition de gauche
ont été refusé par le gouvernement et la
droite excusez-moi de vous le dire main
dans la main c'est bien qu'il y a un
clivage et ce clivage il est gauche
droite avec deux visions de société cela
m'amène à la seconde raison pour
laquelle nous voterons contre ce texte
le ministre le maire qui est le candidat
permanent toujours absent signalit je le
cite ce budget représente la fin d'une
époque celle du quoi qu'il en coûte il
évoquait aussi le fait que le temps des
économies est venu la question c'est
quelles économies et pour qui d'abord
sur le bouclier énergétique c'est 2,3
milliards de perdus pour les ménages
alors que la hausse des prix de
l'énergie continuera en 2024 à hauteur
de 10 %. les grands groupes énergétiques
eux vont bénéficier d'aide du
gouvernement 42 milliards côté
collectivité et contrairement au
discours sur l'augmentation de la DGF
l'exercice financiers se traduira par
d'importantes pertes financières pas
d'indexation la DGF sur l'inflation
manquant marquant une baisse de 5,6
milliards d'euros tout transfert
confondu en Euroc concourant poursuite
de la suppression de 19,6 milliards
d'euros de cveae et perte potentielle de
la dynamique pour les communes et cet
affaiblissement de l'action publique a
été aggravé et je vous le dis mes
collègues par vous la droite sénatoriale
agriculture alimentation forêt affaires
rurales moin 4 vers 7 milliards d'euros
immigration Mo 2 milliards plan de
relance moin 1,4 milliards compte de
concours financi audiovisuel plus Mo 4
milliards et surtout et surtout cohésion
des territoires Mo ins 19 milliards le
gouvernement et la droite ont des
projets qui se confondent avec un même
centre de gravité des économies pour les
ménages les services publics et
l'égalité territoriale mais pas pour les
actionnaires ni les plus haut revenus
des économies aussi contre la
planification écologique et là vous avez
raison monsieur
CASNAV je vous cite nous sommes loin de
la ution écologique et là-dessus
franchement impossible de douter de
votre franchise j'en viens à la dernière
raison de notre vote contre c'est celle
de l'adage classique socialisation des
pertes et privatisation des profits
autrement dit vous faites le choix de la
dette au détriment de l'impôt sansetté
peut être utile pour investir c'est ce
qu'on appelle une dette saine oui mais
le problème est l'ampleur et la
structure de la dette d'abord il existe
écoutez-moi bien 1800 à 200 dispositifs
d'aide aux entreprises
56 % seraient des subventions 5 %
seraiit des allègements fiscaux ensuite
la dette vient aussi en grande partie du
refus d'une fiscalité juste et
progressive pour tous pour la très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens le
système fiscal français est progressif
cependant à partir de 0,1 % les plus
riches il devient dégressif chutant à 26
% pour les
0,002 % les plus fortunés mais voilà o
vient la dette et le déficit avec 145
milliards d'euros de déficit et 280
milliards d'endettement nous attigons un
record il faut parler clairement d'une
dépendance au marché financier cette
bulle a été créée par les intérêts de la
dette qui produisent une fragilité de
l'État l'argent prend alors le dessus
sur nos valeurs ces trois valeurs qui
nous lient liberté égalité fraternité et
je vous le dis l'argent ne fait ni la
nation ni la démocratie et aussi la
dette privée des entreprises et entre
entreprises un tabou on n jamais le
droit d'en parler et pourtant ça
représente 62 % du PIB contre 105 % en
moyenne dans la zone euro la dette
publique à côté fait pas figure et se
déresponsabilisant le gouvernement fait
le choix de la décentraliser ouz et de
la faire porter sur les collectivités et
sur les salariés qui n'en sont pourtant
pas responsables pour conclure nous
voterons contre ce budget il va pas
améliorer la vie quotidienne des
Français il ne gladera pas la crise
énergétique ni la bombe sociale qui
s'amorce devant nous avec la crise du
logement s'il y a bien un changement
dans la politique gouvernementale c'est
que le gouvernement vient de s'extraire
de la gestion des urgences le
gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale se
sont finalement entendus hier soir dans
la nuit en votant un article d'équilibre
avec un solld de 42 milliards tout était
déjà réglé entre pque de fond et faux
semblant de conflit
la conclusion de cela c'est que la
droite n'a pas de budget alternatif à
celui du gouvernement les citoyens les
syndicats les associations et
l'opposition de gauche eux en ont un il
n'est ni réaliste et ni extrémiste il
est nécessaire 2024 sera peut-être
l'année de résistance nouvelle populaire
large et unitaire et là je vous le dis
tout est
possible
merci la parole est à notre
collègue bac pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen la
parole monsieur le
président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers
collègues ainsi s'achève le marathon
budgétaire consacré au projet de loi des
finances pour
2024 mais contrairement au marathon
olympique dont la distance est immuable
notre marathon budgétaire ne cesse de
s'allonger année après année en raison
du nombre croissant d'amendement déposés
le droit d'amendement est un droit
fondamental du parlementaire sur lequel
il serait dangereux de revenir mais
peut-être faudra-t-il encore modifier
notre règlement en raison de la
contrainte de durée Pr pour l'examen de
cette loi des finances en
attendant je me félicite que les règles
d'examen desmissions selon un temps
programmé é été respecté par tous les
groupes avec il faut bien le dire une
attention permanente et bienveillante du
président de la commission des finances
que je remercie ainsi que le rapporteur
général et Monsieur le Ministre pour
leur présence assidue et leur pédagogie
leur
écoute le Sénat a porté au texte
présenté par le gouvernement de
nombreuses modifications dont il faut se
féliciter sur la partie recette du
budget je tiens à souligner les avancées
inscrites par le Sénat dans le texte
avait plus d'un milliard et demi d'euros
Bénéfic des collectivités territorial je
citerai à titre d'exemple l'abonnement
d'un fond d'urgence pour les inondations
et une dotation incendie pour les
communes rurales une revalorisation de
la
DGF la prolongation du filet de sécurité
énergétique pour les
collectivités une dotation
supplémentaire pour les départements
l'éjargissement de la dpel au communes
de moins de 1000 habitants sans
condition de ressources et 3000
nouvelles communes élugi les FFR
également sont une avancée pour la
ruralité bien que le groupe
RDS regrette le rejet de son amendement
pour le beau département du Lot qui se
trouve du dispositif pour quelques
habitants en raison d'un problème de
procédure que nous av'avions pas
vraiment appréendé monsieur le ministre
nous comptons sur vous c'est acquis je
vous remercie mais aussi les dotations
confortées pour les chambres consulaires
essentielles dans nos territoire Chambre
d'Agriculture Chambre de commerce et
industrie Chambre des Métiers je
n'oublie pas
l'élargissement à tout le territoire du
pré à tau zéro pour soutenir l'accession
à la propriété et le secteur du logement
concernant la seconde partie du budget à
savoir les dépenses avec les crédits
répartis par mission la plupart des ces
missions ont été adoptées après le vote
d'amendement par le Sénat à l'exception
de la mission cohésion des territoires
la mission plan de relance investir pour
la France en 2030 celle portant sur
l'administration générale et
territoriale de l'État celle sur
l'immigration Asie et intégration
accords monétaires internationaux avance
l'audiovisuel et enfin celle sur le
sport et la vie
associative si les amendements proposés
par le gouvernement et adoptés par le
Sénat ont toutes leur chance d'être
conservé dans le cadre d'un probable 493
à l'Assemblée nationale on peut
s'interroger sur le sort qui sera
réservé aux amendements déposés et
adoptés par les sénateurs en séance ou
en commission il convient de noter que
le Sénat a fait preuve de responsabilité
dans l'examen de ce texte puisque si de
nombreuses avancées ont été votées en
particulier pour les collectivités
territoriales le déficit global a été
réduit par rapport au texte initial du
gouvernement mais ce déficit devient de
plus en plus inquiétant et la charge de
la dette va être encore aggravé dans les
années qui viennent avec la hausse des
taux
d'intérêt alors depuis 3 ans an que je
siège dans cette assemblée lorsque je me
regarde un peu en arrière je soit par
soit que les événements que nous avons
connu la crise sanitaire la guerre en
Ukraine l'envolé des prix d'énergie ont
rendu toutes les prévisions
obsolète avant même que l'encre le temps
de
sécher alors faudra-t-il demain faire
appel je le sais au Mar de café ou à la
bour de cristal pour voir l'avenir alors
où je vais prime il semblerait que les
prévisions gouvernementales soient
optimistes mais au vu de ce que nous
avons vu et de ce que je viens de dire
je me contenterai du conditionnel à la
matière en ce qui concerne la
fiscalité je me tiens à rappeler que les
commtivés local ont de moins en moins
d'autonomie fiscale et que désormais
l'État ne conserve plus que le tiers du
produit de la TVA le coût global de la
tête de la France aujourd'hui dépasse
des 54 milliards d'euros et nous devons
collectivement nous en inquiéter car
lorsqu'on doit aller voir son banquier
tous les mois on est à sa merci comme
certains l'ont dit c'est une
évidence mais là aussi au risque de me
répéter ce n'est pas sur les services
publics qu'il faut s'acharner car la
population en a besoin mais sur notre
suradministration plétorique et
paralysante enfin avec mes collègues du
groupe RDSE nous nous réjouissons qu'une
quinzaine de nos amendements aent été
adoptés je souligne aussi que sur
certaines missions des amendements ont
été retirés en échange de l'engagement
du gouvernement de régler les
problématique soulevé ça a été le cas
par exemple pour le financement des
contats d'apprentissage dans les
collectivités avec un accord avec le
CNFPT
ou encore sur les pensions de réversion
pour les veuves de harqu où nous avons
retiré nos amendements devant
l'engagement du gouvernement pour
conclure je voterai ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 et le groupe des RDSE
se partagera entre approbation et
abstention je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègu la parole est à notre collègue
Didier rambau pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates prog
[Applaudissements]
indépendant monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
au début du mois d'octobre vous nous
avez promis un contrebudget un budget
responsable un budget d'équilibre le
budget d'une majorité sénatoriale à la
hauteur de ses responsabilités à la fin
de nos 70 Hees de débat ce contrebudget
le voilà et il est temps de faire les
comptes je vous assure qu'on n'est pas
déçu du voyage je reprenais votre
manifeste d'il y a 2 mois ce sont 34
pages de promesses d'un lendemain
meilleur par des chemins exigeants 34
pages pour le renforcement de l'État la
fin des petites économies le retour
d'une vraie politique familiale de
droite 34 pages d'économie sur sur le
RSA laame l'hébergement d'urgence et
l'aide publique au développement je vous
invite tous à le lire c'est beau c'est
bleu c'est grand le président marlex
défendait ce projet comme un un rempart
à la politique du chien crevé au fil de
l'eau reprenant ainsi l'expression
d'André tardieux qui fut trois fois
président du conseil sur la 3e
république je vous rappellerai que si
elle a sombré dans la valse des cabinets
c'est dans votre valse des milliards que
ce budget aura fini de sombrer quelques
mots sur la première
partie car dès le départ l'amendement du
président rotillot sur le ccient
familial a été rejeté par vos amis
centristes suivi d'un nouveau revers
pour le groupe majoritaire sur
l'assurance vie victime de votre
majorité relative et oui vous aussi nous
ne comptons plus les taxes nouvelles
votées à votre corps défendant par vos
amis centriste sans compter les
nombreuses niches fiscales créées cette
première partie c'est le manifeste
politique de l'Union centriste pas votre
budget reconnaissons-le si la première
partie se résume à des critiques
injustifiées et à vos incohérences la
seconde partie démontre
l'irresponsabilité de la majorité
sénatoriale mais elle soulligne mais
elle soulligne nos
désaccords plus plus de crédit pour le
sport mais l'année même des Jeux
Olympiques aucun budget pour la
politique migratoire plus de politique
logement avec le rejet en bloc de la
mission cohésion des territoires la fin
de la mission plan de relance et j'en
passe tous tous les crédits de ces
missions ont été rejetés pour des
raisons que je peine encore une fois à
comprendre car vous nous dites que c'est
pour marquer un desésaccord politique
mais vous pouviez proposer un contre
buudget et c'était d'ailleurs votre
ambition de départ que vous n'avez cessé
de répéter dans la presse mais au pied
du mur vous n'avez su construire une
alternative crédible et ne nous y
trompons pas si vous avez une majorité
vous êtes responsable du texte que vous
rendez vous demandez de conserver les
apports du Sénat on je sais même plus
vraiment de quoi vous parlez de la
disparition comme par magie de
la de la disparition comme par magie de
la dette covid vous la retirez du texte
et nous envoil la débarrasser et comme
par miracle cela vient améliorer encore
votre solde la gauche en arrivé vous
l'avez fait parlez-vous des des
centaines de milliers de postes de
fonctionnaire supprimé on ne sait même
où pas où à l'éducation nationale dans
la polilce chez les magistrats chacun
peut aller voir votre amendement il est
public vous n'avez pas eu le courage
d'aller au-delà de la formule
incantatoire et de nous dire où vous
voudriez supprimer ces
postes monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur rapporteur général si demain
vous êtes en responsabilité je veux bien
croire que dans un an ou deux les
comptes seraient rétablis mais à quel
prix il n'y a plus de stratégie
d'ensemble car chacun il va son petit
amendement et despenses entiers du
budget sont pas
par pert et profits pour financer les
quelques dépenses au profit de votre
électorat c'est ça que vous appelez un
État fort au rendez-vous des défi du
siècle l'irresponsabilité coûte cher
surtout quand elle préside aux décisions
de toute une famille
politique pegy disait le cantisme a les
mains pures mais il n' pas de main le
groupe aura bientôt un budget à
l'équilibre mais il n'a pas de budget
mes chers collègues cette
irresponsabilité d'autant plus
regrettable que la prière partie de
voter des choses positives pour nos
finances publiques je pense à la
réduction de l'avantage fiscal pour les
meublés touristiques à la déliaison des
taux de la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires que nous avions
tant entendu et que le ministre nous a
permis je pense également la création
d'une d'une taxe streaming pour les
plateformes payantes et gratuit dans le
but d'abonder le budget du Centre
national de la musique une idée proposé
par notre ancien collègue Julien
Bargeton par ailleurs je Déore je
déplore encore une fois un nombre
d'amendements qui ont été votés dans
l'hémicycle lors de l'examen d'missions
je pense au délai de carence dans la
Fonction publique d'État à la diminution
de 10000 postes chez les opérateurs de
l'État au rejet des crédits du compte
spécial avance à l'audiovisuel public
sans oublier la baisse des moyens
alloués à l'aide médicale d'État
pourtant indispensable d'un point de vue
de la sécurité sanitaire comme d'un
point de vue humanitaire mes chers
collègues comp tenu des des amendements
votés en première partie du texte et et
des profonds désaccords que nous avons
sur les missions rejetées en deuxième
partie force et de constater que le
budget qui sort du Sénat ne ressemble à
rien il ne ressemble ni un budget digne
d'un parti de gouvernement ni même un
budget tout court ce n'est ni plus ni
moins qu'un texte à trou où les failles
s'accumulent des politiques non
financées comme sur le log notamment sur
le logement des coups drabau qui
ressembl plutôt à des coups de hache des
amendements non évalués et enfin des
économies de plusieurs milliards d'euros
danst aucun contour n'est défini
d'ailleurs en parlant de vos économies
je pointe là encore vot mauvaise fois
car si le gouvernement décidait de
garder les prétendus àort du Sénat vous
seriez ensuite les premiers à lui
reprocher l'effondrement de l'État et du
service public mes chers collègues du
groupe LR la entre la première partie
qui ne nous convient en rien et la
seconde partie qui ressemble plus à un
texte à trou qui un
véritable budget
le seul vote raisonnable serait de vous
abstenir comme le fera le groupe
RDPI la
[Applaudissements]
parole la parole est à notre collègue
Thierry k le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicainz la
[Applaudissements]
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
ministreègu runi afin de clore l'examen
de ce projet de loi de finance pour
2024 le vote que nous apprêtons à faire
n'a de solennel que le nom tant après un
éè 493 les parlementaires que nous
sommes pouvons légitimement nous
interroger sur la mission pour laquelle
nos électeurs nous ont élus je tiens à
vous le dire monsieur le ministre les
heures que nous avons passé de jours
comme de nuit dans cet hémicycle ne
saurait être balayé par le choix d'un
seul homme
dans une société où la crise
démocratique est de plus en plus
prégnante nous ne pouvons nous résoudre
à accepter que le Parlement ne soit plus
qu'une caisse d'enregistrement de
décisions qui sont prises hors de son
sein d'ailleurs le sainglan camouflé que
le gouvernement a subi hier et la
manifestation claire que cette méthode
n'est plus acceptée car devenu trop
pidacceptable si nous ne sommes pas
capables de réinventer un mode
d'organisation politique qui soit plus
souci des aspirations de nos concitoyens
alors d'autres s'en chargeront cela qui
laisse à penser à des concitoyens
incrédules que le problème serait notre
système démocratique je le dis avec
force l'effondrement des croyances
associé à la démocratie représentative
devrait nous préoccuper au plus haut
point
rentrons désormais dans l'analyse du
texte que nous avons
examiné je l'avais annoncé lors de la
discussion générale ce budgetit face à
un triangle d'incompatibilité que 3
semaines de séances n'auront pas réussi
à
solutionner durant nos débats comme
prévu l'obsession du gouvernement à
maintenir la baisse des impôts est
entrée en collision avec celle de
réduire le déficit public mais monsieur
le ministre vous n'êtes pas une
incohérence prêt j'en veux pour preuve
les moyens prétendumement mobilisé en
faveur des investissements verts qui
sont objectivement loin de répondre aux
objectifs de décarbonation que vous êtes
vous-même fixé enfin comme si
l'antagonisme n'était pas suffisant vous
avez essayé de nous convaincre que les
baisses de dépenses publiques ne se
feraient pas au détriment des plus
fragiles d'entre nous mais personne
n'est dupe sur ces ban pourortant sur le
papier la promesse était
alléchante ce budget devait être un
moyen de consolider nos finances
publiques tout en continuant de baisser
la fiscalité et d'investir pour l'avenir
ce en même temps très macronien c'est
une nouvelle fois fracassé sur le mur
des réalités et votre postulat de départ
constitue un vœux pieux bien loin de la
réalité votre boussole reste la baisse
systémique des impôts sur le
capital néanmoins je note que pour ne
pas apporter de piste de financement
nouvelle vous avez refusé comme comme
chaque année depuis 2017 d'aborder des
sujets structurants tels que la
fiscalité du capital ou la contribution
des plus aisés à l'effort collectif de
redressement des comptes publics nous
regrettons que tout au long de nos
séances vous futes dans l'incapacité de
sortir de votre céité dogmatique que ce
soit votre refus d'instaurer un ISF vert
ou la suppression de la flat taxe en
passant par une réelle taxation des
dividende rien n'aura trouvé grâce à vos
yeux ce jusqu'au boutisme fiscal
néanmoins un cou car votre politique de
l'offre faite de désarmement fiscal
permanent ne permet pas de réduire la
dette dont vous nous parle temps à
longueur de débat pour reprendre une
expression chère à la majorité
présidentielle vous démontrez
effectivement qu'il y a pas d'argent
magique et votre fragilisation de la
fiscalité n'est pas
tenable à ce propos j'aimerais vous
redire vous rappeler que s'il y a bien
une dette dont il faut tenir compte en
priorité c'est la dette écologique et je
vous le redis celle-ci est n'est ni
négociable ni repoussable ni
renouvelable c'est pour cette raison que
nous pensons nous pensons qu'au cœur du
budget aurait dû figurer la bifurcation
écologique pour atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone 34 milliards d'euros
sont nécessaires les 7 milliards que
vous nous avez proposé dans ce budget
nous semblent bien dérisoir et sachez
que l'explication qui consiste à dire
qu'ils seront multiplié dans les
collectivités territoriales où les
organismes de financement public ne nous
a absol ent pas convaincu avec une mise
de départ de l'État si faible comment
croire à la multiplication des pains
cette multiplication
providentielle interviendrait donc au
même moment où vous demandez aux
collectivités de baisser leurs dépenses
le en même temps à ses limites pourtant
nous avons souhaité vous aider à trouver
des ressources nécessaires avec par
exemple la restauration d'un ISF
climatique comme je l'ai précédemment
évoqué
mais dont je déplore qu'il n'est pas
trouvé grâce à vos yeux enfin alors que
l'inflation persiste et touche de plein
fouet les budgets des collectivités
territoriales augmentant sensiblement
leurs dépenses contraintes vous avez
refusé notre proposition d'indexation de
la DGF sur l'inflation pour 2024 la
droite sénatoriale si prompte à
s'autodéfinir comme intercesseur de la
défense des territoires a brillé par son
absence de soutien à cet amendement
visant à donner une respiration
financière à nos
collectivités par ailleurs l'avenir des
ruralités est peu lisible t la
cacophonie qui s'est joué durant
l'examen de l'article 7 a été ridicule
de même quand 75 % des articles du
projet transmis au Sénat l'a été sans
étude d'impact le gouvernement porte une
responsabilité forte en la matière et
une association plus appropriée des
parlementaires aurait permis d'éviter
cela Monsieur le Ministre tout cela
fleurbon
l'amateurisme sur plusieurs sujets
majeurs au final personne n'y a rien
compris et je souhaite que
l'atterrissage sur les zonages des
ruralités comme sur d'autres questions
se fassent le plus en douceur possible
en intégrant les demandes légitimes des
territoires il est un autre atterrissage
dont l'issue me semble incertaine c'est
celui du devenir de nos amendements
vootés sur ces bans après nombreuses
heures de séances et cela me permet de
revenir à mon point de départ quelle
démocratie voulons-nous en France en
2023 pour ne prendre quelques exemples
concrets monsieur le ministre allez-vous
balayer d'un revers de la main notre
amendement prévoyant 350 millions
d'euros supplémentairire en faveur des
mesures agro-environnementales et
climatiques allez-vous revenir sur la
suppression de cette scandaleuse niche
FIFA instaurée à l'Assemblée nationale
allez-vous maintenir le PTZ pour les
primos accédents sur l'ensemble des
territoires comme nous vous l'avons
proposé allez-vous accepter le maintien
du fond de soutien aux activités
périscolaires que nous jugeons très
important autant d'exemples sur lesqu la
balle est dans le camp du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre parce que nous ne
nous faisons aucune illusion le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
votera contre ce budget tant il nous
apparaît iniique à sens unique et ne
permet pas de relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains qui s'imposent à
[Applaudissements]
nous le Sénat va procéder au vote sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finance
pour
2024 je rappelle que le scrutin public
est de
droit conformément à l'article 6 du
règlement il va être procédé un scrutin
public à la
tribune ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
placeront un bulletin bleu dans l'urne
prévu à cet effet ceux qui souitent
voter contre placeront un bulletin rouge
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir placeront
un bulletin blanc donc pour un bulletin
bleu contre un bulletin rouge abstention
un bulletin blanc vos bulletins de vote
sont à votre disposition dans
l'enveloppe placée dans le tiroir de
votre pupitre si vous êtes titulaire
d'une délégation de vote vous y
trouverez également une enveloppe
contenant les bulletins de vote de votre
délégant
j'invite madame Sonia de la provotter et
Philippe tavaro secrétaire du Sénat à
supervisé les opérations de vote et donc
à nous
rejoindre au
sort la lettre par lequel commencera
l'appel
nominal exactement c'est la lettre M
lettre
M madame
met vous
préparer en descendant un peu à l'avance
les lettres monsieur
[Musique]
malur monsieur
Mandelli
monsieur
Marc madame
deco madame Margaté
monsieur
Marie monsieur
Marseille Monsieur Pascal
Martin madame Pauline
Martin monsieur
[Musique]
Masset
ch monsieur
Moret
monsieur
medeviel Monsieur M monsieur
ménien
monsieur
méouli monsieur
Ménonville madame
Mercier merci
monsieur Meril
loup monsieur
Michalet monsieur
Michot mich madame micouot
monsieur
Milon monsieur
Mison Monsieur Mohamed
swali madame
Monier
monsieur
[Musique]
Montauger monsieur de
Montgolfier madame main
des monsieur
mouiller madame
müerbrown lettre
N madame
nadille madame Nara
CIN monsieur
Madame
nedéc Monsieur de
Nicolaï madame
Noël monsieur
nougin lettre
O madame
Olivier monsieur omain
W
monsieur
wizil monsieur
ououia lettre
P monsieur
Paco madame
Monsieur
panouzi Madame Paoli
gagin monsieur
paridi
monsieur
patient monsieur
patria monsieur
Paul
monsieur
Paumier monsieur
peva monsieur
perneau monsieur
Perin
madame
per madame
Pétrus il est
là Madame
finera M
finer monsieur
Piednoir
monsieur
pilfer monsieur
plat madame
Pluchet Monsieur
pointerau Madame
ponmonge
madame
pouirol madame
prima madame
puissa lettre
R monsieur
Rambo
monsieur
Rapin monsieur
ravier monsieur
renal monsieur Redon
sarazi monsieur
rechart
madame Renaud
garabédian monsieur
retaillot monsieur
Renault Rena il est passé il
passé
madame
Richard madame
Richer
peut pas faire passer oui oui
oui
il il
a Monsieur
Ritman
si elle est
descend madame
Robert monsieur
Rochette monsieur
rofricht monsieur
on monsieur
rejoint madame
Riché Monsieur
rejo Madame
Romanie
monsieur
Ross madame
Rossignol monsieur
rou elle arrive
Arve monsieur
Ruel lettre
S madame
SAP monsieur
salmon monsieur
Sori monsieur
satarel
monsieur
Savin Monsieur savol
D madame
Schalk madame
chilinger madame
Sonet
monsieur
sidau madame
sylvani monsieur
sol madame
sologoub monsieur
saumon madame swiiris
monsieur
stanion monsieur
Zurek monsieur
spinner lettre T
monsieur
Tabaro
voilà monsieur
tmal madame
ttoanoui monsieur
Théophile monsieur
tisso lettre
U monsieur
usena lettre V
madame Valente Le
Hir monsieur
valet monsieur van
lurenberg
madame
varellas monsieur veous
fort
monsieur Monsieur
veousfort Madame
vantalon madame
madame
vermeiller monsieur
veréen monsieur
Vial
sisieur Monsieur Jean-Pierre
vugel
Monsieur Louis
vugel madame Mélanie
vugel lettre
W monsieur
watblé
monsieur
Weber lettre X monsieur
rou lettre Z monsieur
zan lettre
A madame h
Lian monsieur
Alizard Monsieur
anglar Madame
Antoine voilà madame Antoine elle
arrive monsieur
[Musique]
aussi madame apoursopoli
Monsieur
Arnaud madame
Artigalas lettre
B monsieur Jérémy
Baky Monsieur Jean bat
monsieur
Bansard monsieur
Baros monsieur
bas
laiss passer
monsieur monsieur
Bazin madame
bellim monsieur
Belin
madame
bureau madame
brti monsieur
benaroche madame
Bert monsieur Billac
madame
billon madame billon
ouais monsieur
beits monsieur Étienne
blanc
monsieur grégoryi
blanc monsieur Jean-Baptiste
blanc madame blatrix
conta monsieur
blunvine
madame Bonfanti
d'sa Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur
bonau monsieur
bonnecer
madame
bonnefoie monsieur
bonus madame borquon
Fontain monsieur boide
monsieur monsieur
boucher madame
boursier
monsieur
Bourgis Monsieur Jean-Marc
Boyer Madame Valérie
Boyer
monsieur
BR madame
briquet monsieur
Brisson monsieur
brossa Mame
Brossel madame
Brulin monsieur
bruillen monsieur
buffet monsieur
Burgoa monsieur
Buval lettre C
monsieur
Cabanel monsieur
CADC monsieur
cadiic monsieur
Cambier monsieur
Cambon madame
canalè madame
canailler monsieur
Canevet
monsieur capo
canellast monsieur
Capu monsieur
Cardon madame
Carlotti
madame
carer madame carer
g monsieur
Casabonne madame
casbonne
Monsieur
chayou Madame chin
Larcher monsieur
ch monsieur
chanterel monsieur
Chassin
monsieur
Châtillon monsieur
chevalier monsieur
chevrolier madame de
Sidrac
Monsieur
sigoloti Madame
centu madame
concon madame con
mour madame Corbière
naminzo
monsieur
corbiset ok d'accord d'accord monsieur
courcial monsieur Cosic
madame
kukirman monsieur
cuiper lettre
D madame
Danielle
monsieur
Dantec madame
Darcos monsieur
Darnaud monsieur Daras
monsieur
dabé monsieur
dabress monsieur de
la madame del
lâre monsieur
delcro
madame
DEAS Monsieur
[Musique]
demil Madame
Deen madame
desieur
monsieur
dersin madame
douanau monsieur
Dosu madame
Drexler
monsieur
Dufour madame
Duma madame
Dumont monsieur
Durin madame
Duranton monsieur
Durox lettre
E monsieur
Eblé madame
Espagnac madame
estrosissason madameage
Brig madame
éen lettre
F monsieur
Fagan monsieur
Fargeot monsieur
fav monsieur
fer
madame
Ferré monsieur
fernic monsieur fialer
ouais monsieur
ficher madame
Floren
monsieur
folio monsieur
foissin monsieur
Frassa lettre
G madame
gaker
madame
Garnier monsieur
gay monsieur
Jeunet madame
Gerbeau
monsieur
gilet madame
Girardin monsieur
gold monsieur
Gontard madame
goselin madame Goulet
madame gouachavant
ouais monsieur
grand monsieur grand après
[Musique]
madame
gréhaum monsieur gros
Perin monsieur
grosvallet monsieur
Guéret monsieur
Guerini madame
Gul madame
guidz monsieur
guillol lettre
H madame
av monsieur
est
Monsieur
H Monsieur
Hervé madame
Herzog monsieur
ingret monsieur
auchochard monsieur
hou
monsieur
eugonet monsieur
Husson lettre
I
Monsieur
yacovelli Madame
Humbert lettre
J madame
jacquem madame
Jacques monsieur
Jacquin Monsieur Jean
sanetas
monsieur
jolie Monsieur
jaumier Madame
josande madame
Joseph madame Giselle
Jourda madame Murielle
Jourda
monsieur
Joyandet lettre
K monsieur
caner monsieur
kuchci monsieur KNE
oui
monsieur
kerouche monsieur
califé monsieur
Klinger monsieur couim
côé lettre
L
madame de La
Gonterie madame de la
provuté M monsieur
Laffond
monsieur monsieur
lac monsieur
laméi Monsieur
lawedge Madame la
sarade monsieur
logier
Monsieur
Laurent madame
Lavarde est
pas marqué en
plus si il a une
délégation monsieur
Lele madame
leou
monsieur le
rudulier monsieur
Lefèvre monsieur
delè monsieur le
mooine madame
l'ermite monsieur Leroi
monsieur
Lévi il est passé monsieur
lévrier madame Lincoln
held madame
Loisier monsieur
long madame
Lopez monsieur
[Musique]
louau Monsieur
losac Madame
Lubin monsieur
Lurel
donc deè deuxè
appel j'ai un 2uxè appelsur nouvel appel
nominal 2e appel madame
Conconne monsieur
jaumier monsieur couim moé
côé madame Siris
plus personne demande à
voter le scrutin est donc clos
Madame et Monsieur le Secrétaire vont
procéder au
dépouillement
en remerciant madame et monsieur le
secrétaire qui viennent de superviser
les opérations de vote voici le résultat
du scrutin 98 pour l'ensemble du projet
de Loix de finances pour 2024 nombre de
votants 343 nombre de suffrage exprimés
294 pour l'adoption 191 contre 103 le
Sénat a donc
adopté
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
avec le vote du projet de loi de
finances nous arrivons au terme de notre
ce qu'on peut qualifier monsieur le
Président de marathon budgétaire nous
avons de nouveau battu des records par
rapport à l'an dernier qu' s'agisse de
la durée d'examen avec plus de 151
heures consacrées à la séance c'était
144 l'an dernier ou du nombre
d'amendements plus de
3700 60 amendements nous étions à 3040
l'an
dernier malgré les évolutions engagées
depuis 2 ans forceé de constater qu'il
devient de plus en plus difficile
d'assurer la qualité de nos débats dans
un cadre constitutionnel contraint tel
que est le cadre de l'examen de la loi
de finance je souhaite donc que nous
poursuivions la réflexion avec les
membres de la Conférence des
Présidents pour l'URE je souhaite
remercier tout
particulièrement le rapporteur général
de la commission des finances
Jean-François Husson pour son écoute et
pour la qualité de son travail ces avis
nous ont permis de nous prononcer en
pleine connaissance de cause je pourrais
saluer remercier le président Claude
Rênal qui a rappelé nos contraintes au
terme de délis lors de la réunion des
présidents de groupe c'était le 29
novembre dernier organisé à la veille de
l'examen des missions et qui a contribué
par sa particulière vigilance et sa
pédagogie à ce que les délaaiis d'examen
soient respectés ça n'était pas gagné au
départ je veux également remercier les
présidentes et présidents de Séan qui
ont permis à nos débats de se dérouler
de manière
apaisée je salue les 49 rapporteurs
spéciaux de la commission des finances
les 76 rapporteurs pour avis des autres
commissions ainsi que leurs présidents
et les chefs de fil des huit groupes
politiques
pour leur contribution à nos débats je
voudrais remercier
aussi l'ensemble des personnels des
services du Sénat et des groupes
politique et
particulièrement les administrateurs
administrateurs adjoints et personnel de
notre commission des finances qui ont
été à la tâche pendant toute cette
période audelà des remerciements
permettez-moi de revenir à mon propos
initial je crois qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on
s'interroge
3760 amendements je profondément au
droit d'amendement je vous le dis mais
est-ce que ça a encore du sens c'est
vraiment une interrogation je voulais
faire de manière un peu
solennelle nous aurons à remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier si nous voulons
que l'examen du budget reste un temps
fort de la démocratie parlementaire
d'autant que la situation politique et
le dialogue avec l'autre assemblée et
bien fait que l'essentiel du débat
budgétaire a lieu chez nous et qu'il
faut donc qu'il les sur des points de
force des points essentiels pour ensuite
éclairer l'éventualité monsieur le
ministre de la décision du
gouvernement enfin je voudrais vous
remercier Monsieur le Ministre ainsi que
vos collègues membres du gouvernement
qui vous êtes sucéder au sein de notre
hémicycle en écoutant madame Lavarde
j'ai compris qu'elle était tombée sous
votre charme pour l'examen de la loi de
finances tout à l'heure
alors avant de vous donner la parole je
voudrais savoir si le président de la
commission souhaite ajouter quelques
mots le rapporteur général monsieur le
Président
oui merci monsieur le Président de me
donner la parole pour quelques instants
euh je ne vais pas reprendre l'ensemble
des remerciment que vous avez formulé à
juste titre j'aurais évoqué deux choses
d'abord l'année dernière quand je
m'exprimais comme cela à la fin du le
projet de loi de finances j'avais dit la
coupe est pleine en parlant du nombre
d'amendements
cette année pour rester dans la même
formule la coupe a débordé
elle a débordé et elle a débordé surtout
d'ailleurs sur la première partie
puisque là nous avons utilisé tous les
temps possibles euh pour les temps
constitutionnels pour pouvoir traiter
l'ensemble des amendements de première
partie et évidemment ça pose des
difficultés on y reviendra cela a été
dit faudra qu'on retravaille le sujet
mais il est clair qu'une des raisons
c'est évidemment le fait qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale on n'est pas
débattu c'est une c'est très clair tout
ce qui n'a pas traditionnellement tout
ce qui était débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale de donner lieu qu'à quelques
repris au Sénat mais globalement les
sujets étai déjà prétraités si je puis
dire à l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est
plus le cas et donc tous les sujets
évidemment sont repris c'est logique au
Sénat mais dans un délai malheureusement
ement qui est de 20 jours alors que
l'Assemblée nationale elle a normalement
40 jours pour traiter l'ensemble des
sujets et donc il y a bien là une une
difficulté particulière deuxièmement
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président il
y a eu un très gros travail régulier de
la séance pour améliorer la qualité de
nos débats et notamment en deuxème
partie sur le travail sur les missions
où nous avons pu et je voudrais vraiment
féliciter la séance pour cela nous avons
pu classer les discussions finalement
plutôt que être classé par gage être et
à ce moment-là on a des discussions
communes qui n'en finissent pas et
c'était vraiment devenu très difficile
et on est arrivé à traiter les sujets
par sujet hein donc par sujet c'était
beaucoup plus clair et finalement la
qualité du du du du travail était bien
meilleur donc merci à la séance pour
cela pour ce travail et heureusement
qu'il a été fait parce que sinon je
pense qu'on aurait été vraiment
totalement
débordé merci également je je le redis
évidemment mais je suis obligé de le
redire pour les services évidemment de
la commission des finances euh pour la
chef de service qui est ici le
l'administrateur en charge du rapporteur
général c'est pas une petite tâche euh
exactement euh vous avez pu noter
peut-être les vous l'avez pas noté mais
les membres de la commission l'ont noté
on sé plusieurs fois pour avoir les avis
du rapporteur général parce qu'il y
avait tellement d'amendements qu'il
fallait jouer jour après jour et faire
une commission quasiment par jour pour
arriver à écluser les choses ça veut
dire que toutes les nuits les
administrateurs travaillaient pour
pouvoir traiter au fur et à mesure et
qu'on puisse le lendemain se retrouver
en séance donc c'est un travail tout à
fait particulier j'aimerais qu'on les
réapplaudisse une nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
fois
si on le fait avec le Président c'est
que ce travail il est souterrain il est
pas visible et il est essentiel pour la
qualité de nos travaux et donc il faut
vraiment y insister la séance et
l'administration de la commission des
finances et bien sûr tous les
administrateurs qui dans les commissions
ont préparé le travail pour les les les
rapporteurs pour avis donc merci à
chacun d'entre vous pour le travail réal
disis je ne reviens pas là-dessus merci
aussi de de tolérer euh mes
interventions euh quelquefois un peu
direct euh pour vous suggérer une
accélération à tel ou tel moment en
essayant de prendre garde à ce que les
débats majeurs évidemment ne soient pas
coupés et et puissent se maintenir mais
nous avons ce travail à faire et à
réaliser euh dans les semaines qui
viennent pour repréparer euh le PLF des
années des années prochaines merci à
vous monsieur le ministre pour à la fois
votre présence elle est quand même bien
naturelle mais également pour la qualité
de vos réponses et le fait de pas vous
être trop énervé euh donc ça c'était
plutôt plutôt bien euh la majorité aussi
d'ailleurs des ministres un ou deux on
les a senti un peu plus un peu plus
comment dire voilà euh plus ça les
agçait un peu plus bon on a pu avoir ça
ça arrive euh quelques pas mais je pense
qu'on a fait un travail qui était qui
est utile qui est toujours utile c'est
de regarder l'ensemble du du du budget
on dit quelquefois qu'est-ce qu'il en
reste et cetera oui d'accord mais il en
reste beaucoup d'informations pour
chacun d'entre nous et ces débats
finalement par mission sont majeurs pour
l'information et pour le travail du
Parlement de manière générale donc
encore une fois il nous faut trouver
monsieur le Président vous l'avez dit un
certain nombre d'améliorations encore
pour arriver à faire les choses ne vous
sentez pas obligé systématiquement de
passer par voie d'amendement il existe
bien d'autres façons de porter le débat
parlementaire que par la loi de finances
on en reparlera dans les jours et les
mois qui viennent et puis bien sûr en
lui passant la parole je voudrais saluer
évidemment le travail du rapporteur
général parce que évidemment en
permanence il doit trouver les les
propositions de réponse il doit donner
les positions de la
majorité du Sénat et il le fait
remarquable
et donc je tiens également à saluer son
action merci monsieur le rapporteur
général
oui pardon merci monsieur le Président
merci également au président Claude
renal je veux moi aussi vous remercier
monsieur le ministre je dirais que
l'examen de mon point de vue et j'ai le
sentiment du point de vue de l'Assemblée
sur tous les bancs est réussi vous avez
été à l'écoute quand il fallait aller
vite j'étais très bref pour vous laisser
le temps d'exposer même assez rapidement
et brièvement les points de vue je pense
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
qu'on a démontré que notre démocratie ne
peut vivre que lorsque les assemblées se
réunissent et
délibèrent le le Sénat sur un temps
beaucoup plus contraint avec une charge
de travail évidemment plus conséquente
faute d'exam
à l'assemblée a dû mettre les bouchées
doubles alors en général ça débute les
amendements parce que ici on appelle la
nuit de la mort alors c'est plus une
nuit c'est une semaine compliquée elle
est pas de la mort heureusement même si
à un moment j'ai eu un dimanche qui
était un peu fatal et ce qui me permet
de remercier également Christine Lavarde
d'avoir au piedlevé pourvu avec réussite
au remplacement mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que les temps deviennent à mon
avis compliqués
pour faire vivre la démocratie donc
merci à tous les sénateurs et à toutes
les sénatrices je crois qu'on a pu avoir
un débat serein apaisé constructif
chacun a eu sa part de satisfaction
parfois au contraire c'était pas
toujours évident et c'est vrai aussi
pour laorteur général qui de temps en
temps essu des échecs mais c'est normal
je pense que c'est c'est la vie de la
démocratie et puis le deuxième sujet
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit très
tôt ce matin je veux quand même vous le
redire parce qu'il va dans le même ton
et malheureusement je dirais ce qui
s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée ne fait
que le confirmer je pense que notre
démocratie aujourd'hui est fragile et
donc nous devons plutôt comme nous le
faisons au Sénat depuis un certain temps
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse vivre en
s'écoutant les uns les autres en
essayant de tracer des solutions et des
perspectives et puisque l'Assemblée pour
les raisons qu'on a évoqué 1000 fois n'a
quasiment pas débattu ce qui amènne des
textes beaucoup plus faibles avec des
articles supplémentaires qui n'ont
subi aucun passage devant le Conseil
d'État aucune étude d'impact donc tout
ça fragilise le travail démocratique
alors peut-être par que j'ai entendu
certains sur ces bans plutôt de de votre
sensibilité de la majorité c'est un peu
le jeu ont été je pense un peu sévère
moi je veux d'abord redire que ici le
Sénat a travaillé ça a été dit plus de
150 he pour produire une copie qui
certes n'est pas parfaite mais que nous
vous livrons monsieur le ministre et au
gouvernement et je pense je le redis que
ce
travail doit être pris à sa juste valeur
parce que le Parlement il a deux
assemblées l'Assemblée nationale et puis
puis avec un mode d'élection qui est
différent mais qui est renouvelé par
moitié tous les 3 ans le Sénat qui
exprime aussi la voie de la France d'e
d'une France peut-être un peu différente
parce qu'elle est celle des territoires
et des élus locaux et bien le travail
que nous vous avons livré d'ailleurs
dans des débats je le redis qui ont été
je pense de bonne
tenue maintenant votre responsabilité je
pense qu'elle est grande elle est même
plus grande aujourd'hui qu'elle n'était
avant-ier je le redis en raison des
événements qui sont passés donc je vous
charge d'abord d'en faire le meilleur
usage de ce travail et puis de porter
auprès du gouvernement et de la première
ministre et j' diraai même du président
de la République de dire que ici la
démocratie vit elle vit elle bat comme
le cœur des territoires et que donc le
gouvernement va devoir se saisir d'un
certain nombre des textes des
amendements que nous avons portés pour
les adopter ou les faire faire adopter
ensuite parce que si la démocratie ne
vit pas avec les apports du Sénat je
pense qu'on sera encore plus fragile
voilà c'est votre responsabilité mais je
vous fais confiance pour porter ce non
seulement ce message mais cette
responsabilité qui est une
responsabilité collective
merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci merci Monsieur le le
Président Monsieur le Président de la la
commission monsieur le le rapporteur
général Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je voulais vous
dire quand même quelques mots après
effectivement ces 150 heur de travail
autour du du projet loi de finances vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président les
3700 amendements vous dire qu'on a bien
travaillé qu'on a réussi à se mettre
d'accord d'accord sur un certain nombre
d'orientations que nous partageons moins
c'est la majorité qui s'est dégagé
sur ce texte au moment où on a défendu
le projet loi de finance je voudrais y
revenir sans être long mais d'accord
pour dire qu'à travers ce projet loi de
finance on continue à soutenir les
entreprises à travers la baisse de la
CVAE la réindustrialisation avec le
crédit d'impôt réindustrialisation tous
ces sujetsl vous les avez validés autour
de la transition
écologique avec des des sorties
progressive du du GNR que vous avez voté
la taxe sur les grandes infrastructures
de transport le malus pour les véhicules
les plus polluants nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sur une trajectoire en matière
de de transition écologique et puis sur
la justice fiscale grande première avec
un taux d'impôt minimum sur les sociétés
traduisant l'accord de de l'OCDE je
pense à l'indexation du barem sur
l'impôts sur le revenu qui est attendu
par les classes moyennes je pense au
plan de lutte contre la contre la fraude
fiscale qui a fait l'objet d'ailleurs
d'enrichissement de la part euh du Sénat
et et sur lesquels que nous retiendrons
euh je le souhaite dans le texte final
et puis vous avez enrichi le texte on en
parlait en aparté avec le rapporteur
général l' tque streaming sur lequel
vous vous êtes prononcé des exonérations
à Mayotte des avancées pour les
collectivités territoriales France
ruralité les communes nouvelles et des
sujets sur lesquels je me suis engagé à
travailler travailler avec vous dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois je ne
peux pas terminer ce propos sans dire
qu'il y a quand même des sujets de
désaccords sur un certain nombre de de
sujets on a eu le le président le disait
peut-être les moments les plus les plus
tendus autour de des collectivités
territoriales je n'étais pas d'accord
avec la majorité d'entre vous sur la
nécessité de renforcer encore les moyens
accordés aux collectivités territoriales
nous en avons largement débattu pas
d'accord sur l'évolution du prix de
l'électricité c'était la la proposition
vous portiez avec une augmentation de 20
% du prix de l'électricité on défend un
autre scénario toujours en sortant du
bouclier énergétique mais on a eu un
débat je trouve intéressant quelques
niches fiscales créé au passage sur
lequel j'ai mis des avis défavorable et
puis vous avez ramené monsieur le
rapporteur général le déficit à 3 % mais
là c'est un point de désaccord un peu
entre nous au prix de la suppression de
nombreuses missions cohésion des
territoires relance immigration
audiovisuel publi mais vous l'avez dit l
lors de votre présentation que en fait
c'était pas tout à fait le vrai déficit
qui devait apparaître voilà je je
voudrais pas être beaucoup plus long
vous remercier d'abord pour pour les
échanges que nous avons eu je pense
qu'on on doit pouvoir travailler un peu
mieux l'année prochaine travailler plus
en amont la préparation de de de ce
budget je pense qu'on a esquissé entre
nous un certain nombre de de pistes
remercier naturellement Claude renal le
président de de la commission des
finances le rapporteur général pour la
qualité de ces échanges je dois dire
toujours dans une dans un un
environnement convivial et et de qualité
Christine lavard qui l'a remplacé
effectivement ce ce dimanche funeste
monsieur le rapporteur général et puis
naturellement remercier les équipes du
Sénat qui qui nous ont n ont accompagné
et et j'auraiis également naturellement
un mot pour toutes les équipes de de
Bery qui se sont fortement mobilisé dans
cette période merci à chacune et chacun
d'entre vous merci monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre je vais suspendre la séance
quelques instants afin de permettre à
chacun de s'installer pour le prochain
point à l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue pour quelques
minutes